I should be an actor
I should be an actor anyway what is that
smoking is this that was pretty that was
pretty trying for them using all that
but we need to go rebound for our I have
to banish my brow I have to avenge my
bro I started like trees and [ __ ] here I
don't understand that oh good good good
momento we need a man it looks like the
portal is great on the ground points are
however it seems an orb is needed
much like Alexander's but we where do I
find a [ __ ] my know around Shan why can
I just go in order way out how did you
go run around for I don't understand way
connected to go am I gonna just go hi
I need no herb where do I get my orb the
[ __ ] what is this
nothing of what that door just totally
opened by itself what is this
I am flea you need one arm and my own
voice this way but it's actually that
ways must avenge bro must avenge em kill
barrels and mushrooms fire lights secret
ins what
it's going here I'm super scared oh no
oh no this is bad is it really bad what
the hell is this ah this is the flower
and it's glowing perfect okay
two ways ago hula doula dog king kelana
cough cough blonde a binky Barnett we
will do the top I thought pattern P puff
puff do for and yeah alright since I
always take the wrong path
I'm going to go this way ah always the
wrong path no matter how I do is I
should trust the right I should trust
the Swedish right
what about this stones and [ __ ] I need a
glove the stones let me go
perfect yes I do
I don't care I am on a quest to safe Oh
should I click that I don't trust it
let's read this first read niala study 6
an interesting side effect of
experimentation today it seems being a 4
gram for sacred day what we know of as
Friday the basic meta of our organic
life to find such a domestic substance
of our family is simply mind-boggling
bubbling yet it is earlier flowering in
sense we are all needed you need a part
of the same universe how I feel this
cafe talk is the methods like I excrete
by day for I am for inhabitants is
troubling to say that I don't even hear
what the hell I'm saying when I do that
I got a lot of power card core why do I
say chords chord notes this looks as a
piece of large article as a type of
technology using the newly discovered
science we can learn infinitely more
about the universe in which we live by
instantaneously travel between I imagine
with the matter what I will discover
will forever change ownership
oh man Sumida inertia seeing a saw the
lyric and character native of the planet
role evolution suggests an exaggeration
secretly mentioned them while I found
one disease there is wildlife and for
yeah but no other significance article
ran through the quadrant after what
Ingrid to the Aboriginal diversion the I
press obvious version starting incest
right I'm too bored to read all that
it's like why put all the nose in one
experimental foundry aspire our hair who
literally doll king kelana cough cough
Alana binky Barnett will it do it buff
yeah Spyro games let's go
I'm pull I wonder find find my friends
my birdies found a bro but instead he's
[ __ ] it but it's [ __ ] that I get
buried whoa
he's completely nice and clear now not
really
I suppose that [ __ ] we can learn a
treasure anyway give me one you know
okay no I don't want it come on more
something being really in spite of the
amount of power can take with us we do
not understand enough to comprehend a
thank you sue exactly learn as well is
easy to absolve each power this pull
said there's some stairs or were born in
this 100 Guardians
oh yeah they're talking about the
previous master and stuff like that I
don't want to read about things I mean
pink
it's kinda gross I don't read about
penises never ever write about beans I
said maybe that one time in school that
we have to read about penises as Kanak
word
the same is go here and through this one
tingly tingly and notes
I hate notes but whatever the spires
closed due to recent events blah blah
blah blah blah all right interesting
everything or we could have just gone
straight just ignored all of these empty
bookshelves I bet it was too lazy to put
books in them Hey ah have to put books
mushrooms forever I just gonna go here
what is this
y'all ready painting that what's this
lyric raisin layer oh I I have drank a
lot of layer of rays in my life the [ __ ]
is lyric raisin lyric okay let's go here
but yeah
this looks beautiful
oh I love waves oh hello you are
pointing this man is either being
deceased from Lonnie yes we said school
isn't dangerous
let's read about this guy then walking
up and down the halls with only a matter
of time now one of them off the
guillotine hello person but there's no
way bring back without them noticing
these things they look so much like us
yet so different than to say that it has
my idea to think about they are pals
their coming is well in this key it's
the only way I can keep it
oh we have to penetrate him three
subpoenas like the last time yeah we
have to do it throw this pretension
nothing of course why do I even bother
crap I just want to look one more I like
that there's no tinderboxes I think this
use of tinderbox scissors it's kind of
overrated there's Python is what I think
bro bro what are you doing here bro
hello really I'm still alive somehow I
don't understand he cut off he cut off
da daaaa
he got off my pain s I can see that
thank you I'm sorry ah is that oh wait
it's over here hey you found your penis
where where where let's go no I leave
them there for this one what is up here
can I go here there's nothing there
disappoint this um I'm just gonna shake
in these butt
that's sound coming from
how does he even get inside here how
small can you be that's what she said
haha I'm so funny so that is deep hey
there oh I miss miss no I went in here I
picked up the ladder anime some small
smells like wine maybe maybe maybe I'm
just saying maybe don't rush to anything
right now I'm saying maybe maybe he
wants a night oops
yeah take the wine oh [ __ ] it actually
worked
holy high day huh whoa shut up shut up
shut up by going I'm going [ __ ] so
that's what happen if you drink too much
oh you're turning to her bro literally
don't drink too much wine kid whoa Oh
BRR BRR BRR BRR BRR BRR BRR BRR proof he
totally just fell down the stairs Oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] mushrooms
it was yo hey no I [ __ ] knew it
ah [ __ ] mushrooms know it mushroom
I can't have enough money oh [ __ ] he's
coming over he's coming over it's cool
let's go let's go
stop rollin I want man let's go go
take your wine and leave the guy want
wine
oh [ __ ] huh how the [ __ ] did you see me
take your wine and go bro what does he
want
I haven't done anything but I wanted to
run past him odd idea bad idea bad idea
bad idea by the day let's go a bump
oh [ __ ] you got me [ __ ] I thought I
could make it don't stop movin
ah that was kind of creepy ok good
we don't have to wait for him or
anything wait what am i oh we blocked
[ __ ] always I can't get that
let's go no I jump ah
such a [ __ ]
I think we're done in here we have the
key so we can go to the place where I
wanted to go heyyo experiment oh it's a
lot uh-huh so the only dual Dolph
actually worked yeah yeah yeah yeah hey
hey hey I can't even crab whoa what the
oh crap bro his hair and he's really
really annoying let's go here first
doesn't worry Oh what is this cool cool
cool it's like there's like a lot
oh they're in here ha ha
you think your Todd huh it's in your tab
huh I never seen him this close before
and actually look at him man you are one
you are one sexy fellow huh oh yeah
thank you ha ha ha you think you're
tough huh a good time huh
where's the boss now I just don't have
the room I can't go there I don't have
anything else so I would assume we open
this door now
just hope I don't release them
come on it's only take it
uh-huh the red one we can go we'll wait
backward bro I didn't mean to kill you
sorry and now we can go no really it's
raining oh I love you put them that's
awesome and spying awesome but I don't
have my penis
when is my paradise I need my penis
let's put him here Bert and let's drag
that down
Oh
yeah ask me what I feel like staring at
the sky so Vendela telling Kurt Russell
homie this ain't real life I'll be
making good on my promises honesty is
pop it inside of it is listen but I
realized I could be better than I was
lighter on my seat cooking up the soul
when we fire up the